all right let's get into the Friday
mailbag you can email info
davidpackman.com we sometimes will
include Facebook posts or messages or
YouTube comments or tweets or it's all
fair game if you're commenting publicly
but info davidpackman.com is the place
to email we are starting today indeed
with a YouTube comment it comes from
Robert Robert says my president Trump my
president who I voted for who took care
of America first left an economy with a
1.4 percent inflation everybody was
working then on the first day like I
told everybody I studied this I already
knew the election was going to be stolen
he's going to shut down the Keystone
power plant gas is going to go up he's
going to open the Border this country is
self-destructive everything happened
itself engineered it's all intentional
and you know that and then there's more
but I would be very very much oxygen
deprived if I continued
uh
it's gonna be hard to talk this guy out
of this stuff at Thanksgiving okay that
that I can say for sure
and uh this type of stuff is everywhere
it's quite literally everywhere I don't
know what we do with it
I don't know how we deal with it and we
recently spoke to former Scientologist
Mike rinder
who said oh no no no cult beliefs are
they are very very stubborn things they
are very resistant to change I guess we
would say
uh good luck to Robert
a Dan Roden
and uh again this one of the things that
happens is when we do a live stream lots
of people who have no clue who I am or
about our show will be watching which is
great thanks to the algorithm you know
new people but many of them are shocked
that I'm on the left and I don't just
shut my mouth the entire show and Dan
wrote in about the Abrams dab eight
that's d-a-b-a-t-e and said packaman
I was trying to hear and understand the
viewpoints being espoused tonight but
due to your unnecessary Progressive
commenting I decided to change the
channel and not even give Abrams a
chance right
my opinions made it so that you decided
that you were supporting Brian Kemp
incredible amount of power that I have
Dan goes on to say I think that your
viewpoints are poisonous and not
indicative of most Americans not really
accurate actually
yes I am with Trump and garbage like
transgender should not be taught in
schools again I still what does it mean
to teach transgender I don't know
they're all repeating it I pray that
your children will have a more
conservative viewpoint on subjects that
are internal to homes and not society as
a whole
no prayer needed
uh I think it is quite likely that my
children will have beautiful
uh empathetic open-minded perspectives
not very much aligned with Dan
but thank you and yes if you just want
the debate only there are many many
other places where you can find that
ozan wrote In
with tears in his eyes he says did Mike
pillow ever send you pillows to try out
I heard their normal pillows nothing
special also are you going to appear on
his insane show I seem to remember him
inviting you on while he was arguing
with your Facebook followers love the
show yeah so
no on the pillows pillow insisted during
the interview I'm going to send you
these pillows you could they're going to
be the best thing ever
and I said listen I think you're
completely wrong about voter fraud but
if the pillow's a good pillow I'll tell
the audience and he said his assistant
would follow up his assistant never
followed up no one followed up there are
no pillows on the way he also did not
invite me onto his show so it may make
him as a shock to some of you
he may not always be telling the truth
I'm starting to suspect Daniel wrote in
about Tulsi gabbard and this is a this
is a good question
David at what point do you think Tulsi
gabbard started plotting out her Dem
exit her Democratic exit I do have to
admit I was Bamboozled by her although I
didn't vote for her of course you're
right and in hindsight I see she was and
is obviously a grifter
I just wonder if as far back as 2016 or
before she had already been planning
this that she had been positioning
herself to be a Democrat who would
ultimately leave the left because the
left left her after all that's how the
right-wing pundits have used her showing
her off as a Democrat who they can
depend on to criticize other Democrats
much the way they did with Dave Rubin
both of them took advantage of that to
position themselves for financial gain
and notoriety before ultimately becoming
full-throated right-wingers what do you
think Daniel in San Francisco I do not
think this was something Tulsi planned
ahead of time
tool C is an opportunist and a grifter
okay and as such I mean guys think about
it I understand going from you know I
really think we should have super high
taxes on the rich to saying actually I
think 37 as a top tax rate is fine once
you make above 400k even if you make a
billion bucks like I can understand that
I don't agree with it but I can
understand that but tools you went from
being a Democrat by name anyway in the
Democratic primary
to over the weekend she was a a rally to
end child mutilation and of course your
guess is as good as mine what that means
does that relate to vaccines does that
relate to gender affirming care for
Trans people I don't I don't know what
child mutilation they're referring to
but it's a whacked out event
it's just opportunism it's where who's
interested in me Democrats were not
interested in Tulsi she got what one two
percent of support in 2020 in the
primary and just nobody cared because it
was also boring same thing with Trump
right I mean listen if Trump did his
shtick and said I'm running in the
Democratic primary haha maybe he makes
one debate and then he's gone Trump's
not winning a Democratic primary it's
the wrong audience for him he needs
people willing to you know so he ran as
a Republican similarly
the stuff tools he's doing works way
better on the right and she's going full
in so no I think she did not plan this
far ahead
it was just when she ran in Hawaii the
way to become a member of Congress was
run as a Democrat
and I think Tulsi if anything probably
has very flexible political views or
none at all and it's just all a grift
Bill wrote in and says David I have a
question can Trump run in 2024 that is
the 22nd Amendment says no one can be
president who's been elected twice Trump
won in 2016 and he claims he won 2020.
therefore the fact he refuses to concede
the 2020 election means he cannot run in
2024. bill of course you're making sense
but no this isn't going to work because
they've already figured it out this way
and I'll tell you it is they are right
about this
even if you believe
that the will of the people was for
Trump to win
the states transmitted their electoral
votes such that Biden got 270 and Biden
is the president so certainly Trump can
still serve and and I know that I get
the idea right Trump says I ran twice I
won twice well if you won twice you
can't run again
you can't serve more than two terms as
president and Trump has only served one
term so I wouldn't I wouldn't focus on
that too too much Kevin wrote in and
says hey uh David first off I watched
your recent video showing the absolute
Insanity of these right-wing political
hopefuls how these people have gotten
this far is beyond me second do you
think these people pronounce Kamala
Harris's name as Kamala instead of
Kamala because it sounds more Brown for
lack of a better clarifying term it
seems to me they have a vested interest
in making their opponents seem more
other regardless if they turn around and
spit out Melting Pot disingenuity right
after
thanks for your show David yeah I mean
listen
I'm not saying Republicans in their
heads go hey you know what
if I say Kamala instead of Kamala it
sounds more black so I'm gonna do it
I'm not even necessarily saying
Republicans think to themselves I'm
going to disrespect Kamala Harris by
mispronouncing her complicated non-white
sounding name I think it may even be
operating at a subconscious level but
there is no doubt
that part of the reason they can't just
say Kamala or won't say Kamala
is because Kamala Harris is a non-white
woman
subconsciously overtly we could argue I
don't know but there is no doubt that
that is a factor
mayank wrote in about the Gish gallop
and says David sir you spoke about how
to combat the Mike Lindell style Gish
Gallup debate strategy which was super
interesting it made me wonder if you
have any tips on how to learn to deploy
that strategy in a debate yourself I
also wonder what happens if both parties
use that strategy incoherence I assume
yeah so as a reminder Gish Gallop is
when you you say 10 12 different things
in a debate uh it's impossible to follow
all of them it's just like throwing a
bunch of crap at the wall right so you
know during these 2022 debates we've
seen the topic of I don't even know the
southern border come up right and a
republican will go
uh Joe Biden has opened the southern
border and is letting people pour in to
these Democrat Sanctuary cities the
Border was fixed under Trump the wall
was built and we had the strongest
border ever and they're bringing in
fentanyl actually they like to say
fentanyl fentanyl the Phantom is coming
in from China
and it's coming through the southern
border and now it's in Halloween candy
right and
if it's not oh you get 30 seconds to
rebut that right if you get 30 seconds
to to rebut that the way many of these
debates are structured you can't do it
the debates are mostly structured in a
way where you can't fight the Gish
Gallop the best way to have a fighting
chance when you have 30 seconds to rebut
all of that stuff
is to say listen
there were so many lies there I can't
rebut them all in 30 seconds if you give
me more time I will but the wall wasn't
built there is no open border the
fentanyl right and you just go boom boom
boom boom boom
he he or she is lying to you that's your
best shot in a 30-second response format
in a more
extended conversation at Thanksgiving or
whatever
what I like to do is say listen
you just mentioned 12 different things
we can't talk about 12 different things
at once we just we just can't
are you willing to to talk about these
things one at a time so we can actually
figure out what's going on because I
want to know what's really going on
and if you can get the other person to
commit to that
um then you have a fighting chance but
in the debate format it's impossible
because you can't do it in 30 seconds a
Malcolm wrote in and said this is why
Democrats lose
hey David I watched your excellent
stream of the Georgia Senate debate
there was a difference of expectations
Warnock proving he should continue as
U.S senator Walker proving he could
express coherent thought in the English
language I waited for Warnock to deliver
the killing blow he let Walker Express
pro-life sentiments without bringing up
the abortions he has paid for and let
him take a stand on many issues he
doesn't understand or has no answer to
from crime to health care to education
why do you think mainstream Democrats
can't fight Republicans on their own
level I don't want them to dismantle
democracy or perpetuate lies but I do
want them to fight Republicans on their
own ground by fighting hard can we fix
this I was also disappointed so on the
abortion thing I think Warnock just said
he considers Walker's personal life in
the abortion stuff
out of bounds so I think what Warnock
decided not to talk about that but there
were many opportunities for Warnock to
say ladies and gentlemen my opponent has
no idea what he's talking about he just
said about a hundred words there is no
meaning to what he is talking about
here's the truth about ABC if he can't
even explain to you that he understands
this how can we Empower him to be one of
100 U.S senators it is dangerous ladies
and gentlemen the Republicans have done
something dangerous and disresp
irresponsible here he didn't he didn't
go that way I don't know why and maybe
his thought is it would come off poorly
I I don't know why but I was not
thrilled with that performance or many
others Mark Kelly's performance wasn't
good uh it's depressing and I'm sure
there's an explanation as to why
I'd like to hear it and evaluate it for
myself we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com don't miss it